non la controverse en allemagne le pays
s'apprête à faire venir des milliers de
prostituées des pays de l'est en vue de
la coupe du monde
un immense et luxueux hôtel de passe
vient d'être aménagé à côté du stade de
berlin
là-bas la prostitution est légale depuis
quelques années mais c'est préparatifs
entre guillemets provoque tout de même
une certaine émotion enquête
jérôme baugnies brice boussouar à 200
mètres du stade olympique qui
accueillera de nombreux matches un
pavillon pas comme les autres c'est une
maison close dont le tenant sied n'est
pas peu fier de nous faire admirer la
décoration intérieure il attend beaucoup
du mondial je pense que beaucoup de
sponsors viendront à berlin et les
sponsors ont des invités qui veulent
s'amuser
il ne suffit pas de regarder le foot il
faut aussi se payer du bon temps et nous
sommes là pour ça le club a investi dans
le sauna et la piscine les employés se
réjouissent à l'avance de la manne
sportif je pense que les footballeurs
auront besoin de détente et après lehman
choix damart mais attention le bordel à
l'ancienne est déjà dépassé un peu plus
loin dans une fabrique désaffectée une
véritable usine à sexe ouverte en
septembre dernier 250 clients par jour
et leur nombre augmentera pour la fête
du football
6 millions d'euros investis sur les 4000
mètres carrés de ce temple du plaisir au
dernier étage 40 arbeit zimmer salle de
travail
selon les termes du directeur
d'après les estimations du gouvernement
fédéral il y aurait 400 milles
travailleuses du sexe en allemagne
attirant plus d'un million de clients
par jour
depuis 2002 elle pratique leur commerce
en toute légalité
dina paye ses impôts elles cotisent à la
sécurité sociale et compte bien elle
aussi sur le boom économique de la coupe
du monde comme des milliers d'hommes
vont venir
ils vont manger boire et devront dormir
quelque part et puis ils laisseront de
l'argent à berlin la farine les
berlinois vont s'enrichir et dépenser
chez moi je n'y avais trois millions de
supporteurs débarqueront en allemagne
mais aussi des milliers de prostituées
forcé que les trafiquants font venir
d'asie d'afrique ou d'europe centrale
pour les exploiter dans des hôtels
borgnes ou même des appartements
ordinaire coup de sifflet final à la
prostitution forcée c'est la campagne
lancée par le conseil des femmes dalmat
à la règle ainsi des danseurs corporels
et psychiques et elles n'ont absolument
aucune possibilité de se sortir par elle
même concept auprès se forcer ils ont
donc un besoin dead urgent la ligue
allemande de football s'est associé à
cette campagne et veut responsabiliser
tous ces hommes qui se presseront dans
les stades
ici à chaque kifaya c'est aux clients
qui vont dans les bordels sourn de faire
la différence entre une broussaille in
volontaire une prostituée forcé la
police aura donc beaucoup de travail au
mois de juin prochain pour cette coupe
du monde de football autour des stades
mais aussi dans les quartiers chauds des
grandes villes allemandes